and this much anticipated series now
moves to chapter two here in this best
of five well kevin gausman if you look
at his numbers when he was an all-star
before the all-star break his numbers
were sublime but after the all-star
break he has struggled a bit although
he's thrown a little better his last
couple starts gosling walks mookie betts
to start the game and here comes corny
seeger and there he goes and the pitch
is swung on and missed throw the second
the tag late it was a high throw from
posey and mookie bets swipes second base
it's a strikeout for gaussman for his
first out two down so here now is justin
turner there's a shot left center field
but that will stay in the yard back shy
of the running track ruff makes the
catch julio ureas see those numbers in
his last 17 starts as he got stronger
and stronger as the season went on urius
this year will come of importance for
the dodgers as a starting pitcher you're
looking at lead-off man darren ruff
that's a call strike three
got a little off the edge from angel
hernandez and here is austin slater
he drives one
down the left field line deep and it
bounces up and over the wall in the left
field corner an automatic double here
comes buster posey yo two
rosie tried to check his swing went
around he's been struck out and the
inning is over the first down in the
second as chris taylor steps in
and taylor rifles that one into the gap
left center field
over to cut it off is bryant
and taylor rolls into second base with a
one-out double and here is cody
bellinger so ballinger plays first base
tonight for los angeles
and a swing and a miss
did you see posey there he put the glove
high in case location was being given
and gaussman just let it fly off the
bottom of the table right there so with
the pitcher coming up after paula gets
ahead in the count gabe kepler puts up
four fingers to send pollock to first
base
oh that ball is hit hard right field
sinking fast it's down
slater comes up with it throw to the
plate up the line gets by and it's an
rvi single for julio reyes and the
dodger pitcher makes him pay that's his
13th hit this year his 10th rbi now for
odious first and third two out and
that's stings one in the left center a
base hittle driving another run
maurice will stop at second
look he bets with an rbi single and the
dodgers alive and well here in game two
two nothing dodgers in the second and
the pitches swung out and missed a
splitter
to strike him out so first and third
donovan solano at the plate solano into
center field taylor closes
he's got it tagging up is flores throw
comes in late and the giants are on the
board
sacrifice flying an rbi for donovan
solano fourth inning from oracle park
chris taylor will lead off and that
one's on the ground laying out for it
longoria to his feet to throw in time
really terrific play on both ends for
rongorri to spear that thing and he went
down on his belly gets up quickly he
knew he had to hurry with the speed
taylor could put on a play but the dig
on the back side of the play from wilmer
flores
was remarkable here's cody bellinger one
ball two strikes
and he got him foul tip of the strikeout
for out number two bosman tried to make
it seventh straight and he got him a
strikeout to end the inning two to one
dodgers lead tying run at second and
posey here's brandon crawford now
popped him up
playable for turner
justin turner makes a play for the out
two are going here's the three two with
two outs longoria fly ball right field
that's a long run toward the line he's
there he's got it and the inning is over
in the second inning singled home the
first dodger run they had a swing of the
miss he got him gauzeman his sixth
strikeout he's retired eight straight
there's two out little tapper out in
front of the plate
in to get it guardsmen throws to first
in time for the hour gorsman after those
two runs scored in the second inning has
retired ten straight dodgers
justin turner will smith coming up here
in the sixth inning for la and turner
that is fair down the line
corner with his great speed on his way
to second base and it's a leadoff double
for the dodgers here the sixth inning
and here's justin turner here he comes
and a swing and a miss a strikeout for
gauss but a big one right there that's
number seven two men on and out he goes
gaussman
an all-star this year will exit
leon coming in two on one out and here's
chris taylor leon deals up it in lost
him so back-to-back walks and now they
are loaded up for cody bellinger and
ballinger hits one deep into left center
field and this ball is off the base of
the wall
turner is in smith is in it's a two rbi
double for cody bellinger
what a big hit for bellinger bellinger
delivers and the dodgers take a 4-1 lead
big spot for him to come through still
one out second and third the infield is
in
and that ball is in the left field
that's going to get down aj pollock
a base hit two more runs are going to
score police on his way to second a
belly flop double
aj pollock
delivers two for los angeles
and the dodgers had themselves a six to
one lead a one out base runner and posey
coming up 53 hits in the postseason
after his double in the fourth that is
tied with the panda for the most in
giants history
and posey dumps one into right center a
beast hit
wade will stop at second that hit by
posey now puts him at the top of the
list the most hits
in giants postseason history two on one
out here is wilmer flores flores back up
the middle diving stop turner flips it
to the back and out at second base oh
what a play by trey turner covering some
serious ground
not only able to keep it from going to
the outfield to save a run but gets an
out at the bag so now first and third
here is crawford now crawford off the
end of the back fly ball shallow right
that's down base hit a run will score on
his way to third the tag is out flores
cut down
and the inning ends at third base
crawford with an rbi single to score
wade
but flores trying to go first to third
is cut down at the bag with the spin by
bets and the perfect throw
one out of nobody on here's trey turner
swinging a fly ball
shallow center field bryant coming in he
got a late jump he's going to dive and
he makes the catch a headlong dive from
chris bryant nice play two down and they
had him played about eight steps over to
the right center field gabby had to come
a long way and the big fella he's six
five and he can run longoria tonight oh
for two
that one's hit sharply backhanded by
trey turner throw to first is on the
money oh trey turner behind second base
and the scampered to the third base side
of second made a backhanded stamp picked
it up and threw out longoria for the
dodgers against littell will smith leads
off and the first pitch the will smith
is hammered to left back to the wall and
it is gone a home run
will smith who hit 25 home runs during
the regular year on the very first pitch
he sees from zach littell
and the dodgers take a 7-2 lead it's
first and second for la with one away
and now matt beatty will come up as a
pinch hitter
on the ground that's through for a base
hit
taylor around third he'll score another
dodger run and it's a pinch hit rbi
single for matt beatty darling garcia on
the mound for san francisco here seeger
will bat and seeger on the first pitch
he's going to dump one into center field
that's going to bring in another run
aj pollock will score baity on his way
to third and seeger gets into the act
his first hit of the game it is nine to
two los angeles and the giants down to
their last out so two down here is evan
longoria he is over three fly ball to
right
longoria sends one out to bets and
that'll do it the dodgers answer after
being shut out last night four nothing
they respond with nine runs on 11 hits
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes